قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان عدد
الوفيات جراء الزلازل في تركيا ارتفع الى
1988 كما ارتفع عدد المصابين الى اكثر من
سبعه وسبعين الفا وسبعمائه ومن جهتها
افادت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ افاد ان سته
الاف واربعمائه واربعه واربعين مبدا قد
انهار بفعل الزلزال وقال وزير العدل
التركي ان النيابه العامه تعمل على ملاحقه
المسؤولين عن اقامه مباني مخالفه
للمواصفات ما تسبب في انهيارها
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انما
صعب جمه تواجه عمليات البحث والانقاذ منذ
اللحظه الاولى للزلزال واكد في مؤتمر صحفي
عقب تفقده الاوضاع في مدينه اديمان
المنكوبه الى مؤسسات الدوله تبذل قصارى
جهدها لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
للاسف امامنا مهام صعبه للغايه لان اثار
الزلزال طالت 10 محافظات كما ان موظفي
الدوله المسؤولين عن تخفيف اثار الزلزال
هم انفسهم او افراد من عائلاتهم تحت
الانقاض عدا عن ذلك فان حاله الطقس في
المنطقه سيئه منذ فتره طويله الطرق
المؤديه للمحافظات العشر شبه مغلقه بسبب
الزلزال والامطار ورغم كل هذه المعوقات
فان الشعب التركيه اتحد مع الدوله اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ تنسق جميع الجهود من اجل
التخفيف من الام الشعب
اردوغان ان اتساع رقعه كارثه الزلزال يصعب
عمل فرق الانقاذ رغم ان عددها قد يكون
الاكبر على مستوى العالم بحسب وصفه
علي الاعتراف انه رغم ان فرق الانقاذ ما
زالت تاتينا من 94 دوله ورغم ان اكثر من
140 الف شخص يعملون في البحث والانقاذ
جاؤوا لبلادنا وهو ربما الرقم الاعلى في
العالم الا ان اتساع نطاق الدمار يجعل
عملهم صعبا جدا لهذا علي الاعتراف ان
اعمال البحث والانقاذ لا تسريب السرعه
المرجوه للاسف استطعنا اجلال اكثر من 76
الف شخص من ضحايا الزلزال الى محافظه اخرى
ونتعهد اننا سنبني منازل دائمه لكل
المواطنين المتضررين خلال فتره عام كما
فعلنا في زلازل وكوارث اخرى